the Infiniti saga proves that the MCU
can tell a longer complex story with a
satisfying beginning middle and end but
there are a whole lot of stories along
the way that didn't get endgame style
closure the ease of the MCU stories that
were abandoned forgotten and axed back
in 2018 fans turned out by the millions
to see Thanos trek around the galaxy
gathering up the Infinity stones in
Avengers infinity war a year later they
returned to theaters to see how the
story ended in Avengers endgame
balled-up film port the Infinity saga to
a thundering end there was more than one
potential villain attempting to a master
universe ruling power of the six stones
tan Illya to Vaughn also known as a
collector the obsessive elder of the
universe manages to obtain the ether at
the end of Thor the dark world and in
guardians of the galaxy he briefly gets
his hands on the power stone - however
at this point it appears a Marvel
thought the collector had done enough
collecting and his tail wasn't worth
following through on the enigmatic
fellow ends up losing the power stone
and then well Thanos shows up and that's
pretty much that
the big purple bad guy trashes his place
then uses it as a trap to ensnare Gamora
- Vance quest for the stones ends there
as does his story is he dead is his
collection of seedless Marvel carrots
has gone forever we don't know and we
likely never will kill manga Loki the
mad Titan himself Thanos the MCU has has
some pretty amazing villains over the
years however for every good villain
with a great story and definitive ending
there is a baddie with a storyline
that's either never finished or brought
to an abrupt and unsatisfying end take
cross bones Brock rumlow made a splash
in Captain America that Winter Soldier
where he appears with a gritty Hydra
agent that knows his stuff he features
prominently throughout the movie showing
up in the famous elevator fight sequence
tussling with Sam Wilson and generally
helping to reinforce the fact that Hydra
has some genuine teeth beyond an army of
nameless sleeper agents and a few
corrupt politicians even makes his shift
into legitimate villain status when he
shows up in full costume as crossbones
and Captain America Civil War until he's
casually blown up with others a pretty
sudden ending for
you in the comics as a red skull's
right-hand man speaking of the red skull
let's talk about the vague fate that
befores Captain America's most
unrepentantly evil villain sure he shows
up again as of we had Space Ghost on for
Mia but let's be real that role could
have gone to anyone these are bad dudes
that deserve decent storylines and
they're not alone rather than keeping
them in the mix though they've been
shuffled off to atrophy on the sidelines
as the MCU moves on without them Bruce
Banner had a long-term otras path
through the MCU
one of the few main characters to be
recast vanna's journey started in the
dark brooding hands of Edward Norton
only to shift to the light sir more
Avengers friendly Mark Ruffalo once the
first team-up rolled around that's my
secret
I'm always angry
a good portion of Hulk's developing
story was left in the dust
after the recast including Betty Russ
this love interest has heavily featured
throughout the Incredible Hulk as she
walks in the line between being
Thunderbolt Ross's daughter
and Bruce banners friend and that's
where the weird part about the whole
Betty Ross story comes into play while
she has been left behind a father has
gone on to play a key role in the events
of the Avengers franchise the
antagonizing military politician is
slated to show up in Black Widow and
might even be back for future MCU
installments Betty on the other hand has
been missing in action since 2008 well
Jane Foster's reappearance for a major
role in the upcoming Thor love and
thunder after missing out on Ragnarok
shows that any love interest can make a
sudden reappearance Betty Ross and
whatever role she was meant to play in
future Hulk stories have been dormant
for over a decade Bruce banners romantic
relationships within the MCU have always
been complicated his connection with
Betty Russ is strained by Big Green and
his later friendship with Natasha
Romanoff ends up suffering from similar
Hulk induced tension interestingly both
women are the catalysts a calming
Hogtown and allowing Banner to regain
control but in the end the romantic part
of both relationships Peters out without
fanfare when it comes to Bruce and
Natasha torque retention the
relationship between the pair of
characters is primarily fleshed out in
Avengers age of Ultron at all Kai's
farmhouse Nats offers to give everything
up in order to run away with Banner
she even argues that they're in a
monster should be a unifying point
between them of course it should
probably be noted that her monster is a
little more metaphorical whereas Bruce
literally turns into a furious green
behemoth who tears down buildings either
way by the time the movie ends we see
Hulk in control as he heads off to guest
star in a buddy comedy with Thor and
their would-be lovebirds don't reunite
until infinity war when there's too much
going on to be concerned about romance
much like banners relationship with
Betty Ross the Bruce NAT train never
quite pulls out of the station leaving
fans with more questions than answers
one of the best things about the first
two Thor films is that they include his
entire supporting cast Odin and Loki are
there of course but so other friends
I've always been at his side in the
comics Hogan the Grim Fandango and
Volstagg the valiant collectively known
as the Warriors 3 and their formidable
lady SIF
Hogan who led you into the most glorious
battles you did
the Warriors 3-play integral roles
throughout the first two films but in
Thor Ragnarok Baron ceremoniously bumped
off by hella as she conducts her
conquests of Asgard that movie also sees
Odin surprisingly peaceful land and
Loki's all over the MCU even returning
an ends game after his untimely death in
infinity war
that leaves lady's surface a lone member
of Thor's posse to be totally absent
from Ragnarok infinity war and endgame
the whereabouts are an enigma at the
very least it was eventually revealed
that she wasn't anywhere for a while the
rooster brothers explained in an
interview that she had been snapped away
at the end of infinity war but that
means she should have been brought back
by the reversal of fellows to snap right
so where is she
SIF doesn't drop in for the fan Oh
smashing final battle which is where
you'd expect one of the mightiest
warriors of Asgard to be she isn't
glimpsed a new ass card at the end of
that film either it appears that the
entire Lady SIF story is trapped in a
pre Ragnarok time bubble one that fans
can only pray will burst with the
release of Thor love and thunder the
nine realms of Norse mythology figure
prominently in the four films obviously
asgard and midgard better known to us as
earth are the two big ones but six of
the remaining seven also find their way
into the MCU at some points or another
vanaheim and the fiery realm of
Muspelheim are in the opening sequences
of the dark world and Ragnarok
respectively a big part of the first
movie is built around an ill-fated trip
to Jotunheim frozen land of the frost
giants and swats Alfheim is the literal
dark world in Thor the dark world
infinity war even features a lengthy
sequence for Thor visit some mystical
forges of neduvaali infinity war the
balance of the nine realms has always
played a big role in Thor story both
mythologically and in the pages of
Marvel comics but by the time we get to
the end of the Infinity Saga almost all
of them have been conveniently forgotten
by the filmmakers and seemingly forsaken
by the gods the big sticking point here
happens in Ragnarok when Thor initiate
swell Ragnarok the cataclysmic twilight
of the gods for the nine realms will be
destroyed
you cut
me though I know the decal
the ensuing destruction leaves his home
in ashes and there are manor of his
people exiled and in search of a new
home the end up settling in a
picturesque little colony on earth and
Thor proceeds to spend the next five
years are treating into depressed
Hermitage the colony survives but not a
word is breathed about the condition of
the rest of the nine realms are we to
assume that the Dark Elves and frost
giants were just wiped out after certain
laid waste to Asgard but they also make
it to earth and set up colonies is that
who's hassling Korb while he's playing
for nice what the heck happened there
the sokovia accords are a pretty
significant part of Avengers history
while the Avengers definitely saved the
world from an alien invasion in the
first movie
age of Ultron is mostly made up of the
heroes cleaning up their own messes and
by mess we mean an army of creepy
genocidal robots with the voice of James
Spader and to kill the other guy killed
someone first call the climax of the
movie involves the destruction of
sokovia which naturally leads for the
sokovia accords drama that takes center
stage in Captain America Civil War the
question of whether or not the team
should submit itself that government
oversight is so intense that it says the
team of parts leading to a huge fight
that destroys most of the Berlin
airports and involves a handful of
superheroes being locked in a secret
prison the illegal nature of team caps
vigilante efforts is briefly alluded to
an infinity war when Brody ignores Satya
Strasse in order to help his friends but
beyond that the legal consequences of
the group's actions already mentioned
with any seriousness again eventually
the group reunites and manages to bring
down Thanos but what about those down
the calls that caused so much grief in
the first place the world certainly has
a lot more to worry about with half of
its population snap tales of existence
but wouldn't blaming the heroes for
failing to stop Thanos make the argument
even more intense among the survivors
Ross is eventually present at Starks
funeral but beyond that subtle presence
the MCE was now had several movies where
the Accords are either glossed over or
ignored entirely will they ever show up
again was the entire question of
government oversight a moot point as far
as phase 4 is concerned although we
haven't seen it lots of Asian 13 she's
played a pretty important part and Steve
Rogers story the great niece of Peggy
Carter Sharon Carter helped Steve
throughout the entire Winter Soldier
fiasco
and continue to pop up after that giving
a moving eulogia to aunt's funeral and
then ultimately helping team cap in
Civil War the last time we saw Carter in
action she helped cap on his fugitive
squad to get their equipment and send
Steve into battle with a kiss weird as
it sounds it appears the powers-that-be
was setting up cap to for his dead first
loves nice which isn't the best look of
superhero romances ever had
still Sharon's bean caps on again/off
again love interest in the comics for
over 50 years so we get it except after
Civil War Sharon Carter completely
dropped off the radar and cap ultimately
ended up heading back in time to spend
his life with Peggy Carter so yeah it
looks like the MCU gods decided to
circle back to the original love story
and leave Sharon in the dust check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]